good evening and welcome to this Ingram
angle special Trump versus the Intel
resistance I'm David Webb for Laura
tonight who is on vacation and boy do we
have a show for you security clearances
Strip media bias exposed and a potential
major major setback for Special Counsel
Robert Mueller will have it covered
throughout the hour earlier this week
the White House made big news when it
announced that President Trump had
stripped John Brennan of his security
clearance in case you're not familiar
with mr. Brennan's work he's the guy
that went from Obama's CIA director to a
far left cable news pundit among and
from almost the moment President Trump
took office here's what he said tonight
what really gets under my skin is mr.
Trump's lack of decency integrity
honesty and his lack of commitment to
this country's well-being
Anette security mr. Trump time after
time I think has really just
disappointed millions of Americans which
I'm trying to give voice to and so I
know a lot of people think that a former
intelligence officials shouldn't be
doing us I don't consider what I'm doing
political at all now 15 top former
intelligence officials from both
political parties you see them on screen
have come to Brennan's defense release
in a statement that said in part and I
quote we all agree that the president's
action regarding John Brennan and the
threats of similar action against other
former officials have nothing to do with
who should and should not hold security
clearances and everything to do with an
attempt to stifle free speech it goes on
to say decisions on security clearances
should be based on national security
concerns and not political views later
today 60 former CIA officers also
released a letter criticizing Trump's
action against Brennan but President
Trump is sticking by his guns I've got a
tremendous response from having done
that
because security clearances are very
important to me
very very important and I've had a
tremendous response for having done that
there's no silence if anything I'm
giving up a bigger voice many people
don't even know who he is and now he has
the bigger voice and that's okay with me
because I like taking on voices like
that
I've never respected him I've never had
a lot of respect and Brennan by the way
might not be the only one who loses his
clearance the Washington Post reporting
tonight that White House officials have
drafted documents that canceled security
clearances of several current and former
officials the Post reports that Trump
wants to sign most if not all of them
due to his anger over the Russia
investigation joining me now for
reaction are buck Sexton a former CIA
analyst Jim Hanson president of the
security studies group and Chris Hahn
who's a former aide to Democrat senator
and the senior senator from New York
Chuck Schumer gentlemen good evening
good to see you here again good to see
you all right so let's dive right in and
begin with John Brennan this is what he
had to say earlier on MSNBC with Rachel
Maddow I was very concerned and aware
that the Russians were trying to
leverage US citizens in order to achieve
their objectives in the presidential
election while you were in office as CIA
director before you left on inauguration
day
did you conclude that US persons were
successfully leveraged in that effort no
now I'll go to you first buck if the
question is asked if the concern was
there and the answer is no then why is
John Brennan going the way does against
the president that's a question that I
don't think anybody can answer including
John Brennan if you push him enough
people are talking a lot here David
about how it's unprecedented to pull a
clearance in this way by a president but
what's also unprecedented is for not
just a former Intel chief but the most
recent CIA age
not to just be critical of the president
but to be actively undermining the
president calling him a traitor in fact
to the country this man is the
commander-in-chief and Brennan's
allegations have gone far beyond which
you would see in normal political
discourse to the point where you could
even say it's undermining institutions
to borrow from one of the common
Democrat lines in terms of Trump on all
things and I see this now is the time
when there are a few levels here David
one is I don't think that people who
don't who don't have government business
should maintain clearances I think that
should just be a general rule and you
certainly shouldn't maintain it
clearance if you're going on TV and
suggesting that you have secret
information about the president that you
can't really tell but it's what's
informing your judgement that he's
actually guilty of treason that's a big
problem
all right so Chris especially with what
buck just said John Brennan going on TV
is clearance carrying the specter given
his words more weight I think that's
fair to say for anyone in that position
but his answer was no so I'll put the
same question to you if the answer is no
and given what bunk just said then is
John Brennan being honest or somewhat
disingenuous in what he's doing on CNN
or any of the other channels I watched a
lot of that interview earlier and he did
not say that the president was out of
line and he did not say he did say
though that he had new information that
was widely publicized including the Don
jr. meeting and Trump Tower that most of
us didn't know about until this last
summer so there are more information
that has come out and I think this has
led him to believe that there has been
some sort of collusion not necessarily
with the President and maybe a
conspiracy that involved Americans that
needs to be dealt with and needs to be
uncovered by Muller as for the president
stripping his clearance look I don't
think any of us believe that a president
should use the power of his office to
retaliate against his political
opponents that is an American it is a
Banana Republic like move this is not
something we associate with the American
president this is like Nixon's enemies
list except for Sarah Sanders goes to
the podium and reads the names on the
enemies list and if we had a Congress
that was doing its job it would
investigate exactly why
this president was doing this and I
think come January we will have a
Congress that will do its job under the
Constitution and hold this president
accountable through checks and balances
well if they take the Congress I think
we can expect that from the Democrats
Jim to you and this issue of security
clearances they're kept because if
needed they will call back these
advisers this has been common throughout
administrations however if the
administration has made a decision that
they are not going to call you back
because of as they see it John Brennan
is standing out against the
administration they may not trust his
advice and they have the right then what
is it really all about to remove his
security clearance if they're not going
to call him back
why should he keep it if they're not
going to call him back there's
absolutely no reason for him to keep it
because no one is going to trust his
judgment now having said what he did he
basically claimed that the president has
committed treason so the idea that this
is something that the President did that
is Donald Trump's fault it's not it's
John Brennan's fault and the rest of the
clown car of Obama national security
officials who ended up an investigation
into Trump Russia based on a few minor
players in Trump's orbit then they've
added in the DNC funded steel dossier to
the mix and the problem is there was no
Trump Russia so now what we're looking
at is the Democrat deep state collusion
blowing up in their faces like it was a
wily coyote Acme smear generator there's
no there there
all right gentlemen let's bring this
into the mix this is John Brennan again
on MSNBC talking about the Special
Counsel Robert Mueller it's called the
duly appointed special counsel who has
given the mandate to investigate what
Russia did in terms of interference in
our presidential election and who might
have been working in support of Russian
objectives and who might have committed
a crime in that process and so that's
why a Robert Muller is a real national
treasure he needs to be able to continue
with this investigation unimpeded so
Chris Hahn
removing John Brennan's security
clearance in any way impede Robert
Mueller his national treasure is Brennan
seize him impede his ability to carry
out his investigation I don't think so I
think if the president acts towards
going after my lure anymore I think he's
gonna lose some support additional
support in Congress from even people in
his own party but look the bottom line
is this the president did not consult
with his national security apparatus
before he took the clearance away from
Brennan those people might have said mr.
president we might want to work with him
on things that he had worked on prior to
leaving office as a continuation of
government some institutional knowledge
he didn't do that this was a decision
made in the president's press shop to
distract from the Omarosa story and
we're told today earlier this evening
that the president has several others
lined up to distract as needed if the
news cycle gets away from him as it did
this week that's despicable he's playing
games with our national security and
that's not right and I would like to
hear what dan coates has to say I would
like to hear what the current CIA
director has to stay I would like to
hear what they have to say about this
because I don't think that they are are
too keen on this they were saying that
they did not know they were not
consulted and that's just wrong theirs
was taking away there's a process to
take away these clearances David and the
president didn't follow it well he is
the executive buck and he has the right
in consultation is not legally required
but you are in the shop and the CIA
director is not the only one who has the
information he's certainly the head of
the agency and maybe within that agency
the highest classification authority but
others have the information so is the
CIA director the only one that can be
called back if they need information no
I think that's that's pretty overstated
also anybody who spent any time in the
intelligence community will tell you
that there are a lot of people working
on on any one issue and there's a
tremendous amount of institutional
knowledge from people who aren't
political appointees who stay in these
agencies for decades and decades of
their career so the notion that you're
going to have this crisis situation
where you can't bring back some director
to find something out I think
just preposterous that's honestly why
you also hear it described in press
reports as a courtesy and that's why a
lot of these individuals hold their
clearance but it's a different thing to
have that courtesy when you're somebody
who's then in private life versus
somebody who is clearly trading on that
recent access not just for media
appearances and by the way the whole
thing about being silenced is just on
its face ridiculous he's clearly not
being silenced he's on TV practically
every five minutes you're saying Brennan
and all the other anti Trump folks who
are getting lots and lots of airtime an
additional play here and then also David
I like I can understand there's some
concern about political retaliation I
think that's a fair point to make for
some people in some cases thank you but
one I think Brennan is the exception so
far and two this is not that big deal
the people that are suggesting that this
is the equivalent of you know the
Japanese being interned in camps or
anything like that are going way
overboard but that's what we tend to see
from Rush Limbaugh into this of course
you know Rush has been very upfront
about this and here he talks about
essentially trying to overthrow a duly
constituted elected president let's play
it where is it written that John Brennan
above all else must be granted his
security clearance when this guy is
actively engaged in overthrowing a duly
constituted elected president well you
know the answer to the question is
because the left doesn't care about the
Constitution it doesn't care about the
rule of law it cares only about its
power and folks this is none of those
ricochets none of those are
exaggerations well Jamie Anson you heard
it from the Russian err himself so what
do you say to that
I think we saw this it started during
the election it ran through the
transition and continued once President
Trump was inaugurated they've been
trying to stop him they've been trying
to discredit his administration and now
they're trying to get him removed and
there's nothing to remove him on there
is no collusion with Russia there is
however a collection of former Obama
officials and DNC folks who did conspire
to create a controversy
see and who were leaking information a
lot of it potentially classified to the
media that includes Brennan who's a
prime suspect in that along with clapper
and other people who signed these
letters in support of Brennan saying he
shouldn't have lost his security
clearance so they're the ones I think
the problem for him it may flip to be
looking at them as opposed to Trump and
they may get some onion good consequence
go you you know the people who wrote
this letter supporting Brennan include
the man who led the mission to kill
Osama bin Laden which Brennan didn't
leave the mission it's completely our
national security not some conspiracy
nonsense that you just spouted and that
Russia's is is whining about alright
Chris I gave you the last word we've
known each other a long time compared to
you my friend gentlemen thank you